caminar contra todo incluso contra las
deportaciones a México anunciadas por
Estados Unidos para los venezolanos que
crucen la frontera de forma irregular
destacaravana con 200 migrantes camina
desde Honduras hacia Guatemala La
mayoría vienen de Venezuela esperamos un
nuevo futuro porque esto está feo esto
estamos esta pobreza nos ha dejado y más
esas inundaciones que venía nos dejaron
sin casa sin hogar y Estamos buscando
una nueva vida otros también venezolanos
se han cansado de esperar en
Centroamérica no tengo trabajo fijo Aquí
tengo que trabajar día a día entonces
voy Buscando el sueño americano por eso
pero las deportaciones son lo de menos
el camino para llegar a Estados Unidos
está lleno de peligros selvas mafias
animales salvajes y accidentes tres
migrantes murieron el miércoles tras el
siniestro de la camioneta que les
transportaba por el sur de México
Más allá de los peligros y del anuncio
de las deportaciones otros se sienten en
un limbo no saben qué hacer
y hoy nosotros los venezolanos nos
encontramos atrapados en un callejón sin
salida nadie dice nada ni siquiera
nuestro gobierno se ha pronunciado
se ha pronunciado a favor de nosotros
además de deportaciones a México para
quienes crucen de forma irregular
Estados Unidos anunció que recibirá a
24.000 venezolanos por vía aérea